hello everyone and welcome to a truly
wonderful game uh that was played in the
baden-baden tournament of 1925. uh it's
a game between rihadvetti and alexander
alejand both of them are legends in
their own right uh rihadi basically the
father of hyper modern chess and
alexander alejandro you guys know him of
course as the world champion uh but even
without his world championship title his
games are breathtaking and uh well if
you've ever seen a game by alejan you
know what i'm talking about but at the
time this game was played he still was
not world champion uh as um uh well to
tell you a little bit about the
tournament it was uh basically the uh
era after the first world war there
weren't really all that many events uh
taking place especially on a grand scale
you know with big prizes and
famous names so this is one uh such
tournament that had famous names the
only players basically missing here uh
from the from the world top were world
champion uh joseo capoblanca and the
former world champion emmanuel oscar but
uh everyone else was was pretty much
here
and the tournament got organized under
the
uh well not the patronage but uh doctor
zigbert went to the uh
authorities basically in badambad and he
uh inquired as
if it was possible to organize
a big tournament like they did for
example in
uh 18 18 17 1870 there was a great
tournament in badambad and that was won
by adolf andersen uh he wanted half a
point out of the uh ahead of uh first
world champion uh wilhelm stein it
seemed okay he was not world champion at
a time but still it was a spectacular
event and this again is one such event
we're going to discuss who participated
after we check out the game as we might
even show all the games at least all of
the games alejan played here because
they're just um
very very enjoyable but you guys are of
course welcome to chip in would you guys
enjoy such a thing uh so let's check it
out already has the white pieces and he
opens with not diretti opening but with
the g3 yeah the so-called king's fiance
opening we have e5 by election and now
knight to f3 and now uh the thing is um
as i already mentioned that he's sort of
the father of hyper modern chess uh he
uh uh
uh they considered that the center
should be controlled by pieces so you
should put the knight on f3 bishop and
g2 and that way you will control some
very nice central squares here and you
don't want to put your pawns uh in the
in the center of the board uh therefore
your opponent will uh advance his pawns
forward and later you will be able to
undermine them so that's basically the
crude idea and alejan accepts this
challenge he plays e4 knights the d4 and
now pawn to d5 so he grabs the full
center he says all right show me this
hyper modern stuff you you are talking
about we have d3 captures and queen
characters and it is already now as of
move five that we have a move uh or
rather a position that has never
happened again after this game so knight
to f6 aliyah can continue his
development bishop to g2 and now bishop
the b4 with check if this was a modern
game probably c5 would be played but
alejand has his own way of doing things
bishop d2 we have captures characters
and now alien castles we have c4
challenging the d5 pawn and here alejan
goes knight to a6 again in a modern game
c5 would happen here no questions asked
but again yeah you'll see
aliakin is now
uh waiting for c captures on d5 and then
he's gonna re-maneuver the knight knight
before we'll attack the queen recapture
on d5 then he's gonna play c6 and his
knights will be nicely placed after all
of this initial horsing around so see
characters on the e5 knights to b4
attacks the queen and the d5 pawn queen
c4 and knight captures and d5 so the
knights are now very nicely placed 92 to
b3 and now pawn to c6 and here finally
retty castles uh we have rook to e8
putting pressure on that e2 pawn and now
rook f the d1 aligning the rook with
alejand's queen here bishop to g4
putting pressure on the e2 pawn but also
if the pawn moves then the rook would
hang so uh rook to d2 by retty and now
queen to c8 now i think he wants to play
bishop to h3 and trade off this light
square bishop as it's a very strong
defender of uh
white's position so knight to c5 uh now
preparing b for a4 and b5 he says your
attack on the king side isn't really all
that much uh bishop to h3 but now just
bishop to f3 we have bishop to uh bishop
to g4 again offering a trade of bishops
and eretti akan declines bishop to h3
bishop to f3 and the bishop the g4 and
now retti uh does not repeat he plays
bishop to h1 and there was some
discussion here whether uh it was um
uh whether this position was repeated uh
uh uh two times or was it repeated at
three times or rather not it was
repeated once or twice and then uh did
reity have the option of uh claiming a
draw by threefold repetition uh some say
he didn't something he did i didn't um
uh find any uh
decisive proof of um whether it was the
position or or it wasn't uh because they
say that alejand published it like
could never have
uh you know seize that three-fold
repetition uh as alejand does consider
this one of his better games but okay uh
not really not really
the point as you guys are interested in
what is coming next so here alejand
starts the attack he plays h5 and uh he
says all right this is nothing nothing
really now i'm just gonna continue my
play on the queen side he plays b4 with
a6 stopping b5 and now rook the c1 just
putting more pressure here uh we have h4
by alejan and a4 now preparing b5 so h
captures on g3h captures and now queen
to c7 uh we have pawn to
a captures on b5 a captures on b5 and
now comes the move that well it does
take an alien to find
and that of course is rook to e3 that's
the that's the good stuff we can we can
look at this one more time in slow
motion rook to e3 so it's uh beautiful
as it doesn't really do anything uh by
itself but you can't really touch it if
you touch the rook it's game over for
example if captures on e3 uh just queen
captures and g3 king f1 let's say knight
captures on e3 is checkmate so that's
out of the question so what can you do
after this rook to e3 move
uh it's um you know such a such an ugly
move to have to face over the board uh
but it's there and obviously there are
some real captures on g3 action so you
have to be ready for that uh best thing
to do uh in the game knight to f3 was
played uh which is not the most precise
way to do things the only way to play
this is bishop to f3 and after this
white will be white will be okay so
bishop to f3 is the only good way to
counter this rook the e3 brilliancy by
alejand uh point is that after let's say
bishop characters and e captures c
captures and b5 will happen but now you
have knight captures on b5 you attack
the black queen and after queen to a5
rook c to d1 we we defend our rook here
and now rook captures an f3 you can
capture the pawn here you don't have to
capture the phone you could play rookie
one check then capture the rook here so
there are many options but uh all in all
white should be okay here
uh however in the game knight to f3 was
played and it seems like it's the same
of course you you're not allowing rook
captures on g3 but there is one
difference from the line that we've
discussed you know that uh we said that
uh after c characters on b5 knight
captures on b5 was played well here's
the problem and here aliakin shows it
this is the only way to play for win
with black c captures on b5 and now uh
areti just has to step back and allow
alejand to have this beautiful pass b
pawn but he doesn't want to do that he
claims the pawn and now this is a
problem because now alejian's position
is winning but only if he finds or the
only move that wins the game so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find it the only move that wins the game
for alexander alejan while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always looking for
ways to horse around more and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is knight to c3 that's the good stuff
uh this move just uh does everything it
attacks the queen it puts a piece in
between the rook and your own queen it
attacks the e2 pawn threatening check
and a nice fork here
over the rook on c1 so there is no good
way to deal with this but uh uh areti
was prepared for this that's why he
played queen captures on b5 uh but uh
alejand calculated this so far ahead
that you simply cannot blame mereti for
not seeing this and here it comes i i
can't even count the moves how far i i
can calculate it here queen captures on
b7
uh queen captures on b7 knight captures
on b7 now comes knight captures on e2
with check king to h2 and now okay
perhaps uh
it was considering aliyah will capture
on c1 and that's uh you know that's the
end of it but not really uh because of
course then we would capture on e3 here
i can play knight to e4 and what is this
madness
what kind of a position is this the the
knight so we replaced the rook hanging
the bishop on g4 uh the problem is if
the rook is captured here then we play
knight captures on d2 and how do you
deal with this position the rook is
hanging and also your knight is attacked
twice here there just isn't a good way
knight captures on the two knight
captures on c1 and you're up you're up
the exchange you have a rook for a
knight of course this would be
completely winning for alejan so instead
after 94 uh defends with uh engine like
precision he plays rook to c for attacks
um uh well not the knight but if the
knight moves then the bishop will hang
but it doesn't matter knight captures an
f2 and now look at this everything is
defended the rogue defense the knight
the knight defends the bishop uh
what can what can uh already play here
he plays bishop to g2 yeah it's not much
of a much of a move but
there isn't anything better and now
alejin again shows uh everything that he
had in mind bishop to e6 he just clears
the e g4 square for his knight with
tempo
as the rook is hanging rook see the seat
you're putting pressure on the knight
now knight the g for with check and now
what do you play you can't really go to
h1 if you go to h1 rook a1 and you are
getting checkmated in 10 moves uh so you
have to go to h3 but now you are under
the mask of the bishop so now knight to
e5 with check a discovery from the
bishop king h2 now comes rook captures
on f3 beautifully played uh rook
captures an e2 the problem is that
bishop captures an f3 then knight
captures an f3 comes with check that's
another fork king g2 knight captures on
d2 and after rook captures uh of course
you are down a full piece uh you're down
a bishop there's no playing this so uh
instead after rook captures on f3 rook
captures an eq was played but now again
knight the g4 with check and again you
cannot afford to go to the back rank
rook to a1 will end the game that's uh
you know after you give up all of your
pieces then uh we'll just check made you
so king to h3 and now knight the e3
check delivering another discovery uh
and also forking the rook on c2 king h2
knight captures in c2 and now bishop
captures an f3 and it seems like it's
perfectly fine i mean uh of course eret
is only down one pawn but alejand saw
all of this plus he saw knight to d4 the
only winning move for alekhin and it was
only once he played this on 40 that
rihardi resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the problem
is the rook and bishop are attacked if
you defend the bishop uh not a problem
just knight captures rook captures and
look at this bishop
d5 attacking that weirdly placed knight
on b7 attacking the rook and of course
rook to b3 is impossible because the
bishop covers that square absolutely
incredible
and after knight to d4 of course your
other option is to maybe play knight
rook captures the best of giving up the
exchange but after knight captures good
luck playing this you're down the
exchange against aliyah and you're down
upon uh you know aliahin wins this
blindfolded
so uh truly a spectacular victory by uh
alexander yeah and everything started
with this uh incredible uh idea after a
captures on b5 just to rook to e3 the
movie in itself uh does not win on the
spot it's possible to defend it but who
would find bishop to f3
i mean it's uh
it's easy to analyze games like this you
know after uh almost 100 years it's like
97 years after this game was played uh
but and now we just say okay yeah bishop
to f3 and white is better
white is slightly better not better
white is
you know ever slightly better uh but
after knight to f3 it's just all all
aliejin uh you know after c captures on
b5 that there's just no playing this
so truly uh a beautiful showing by eking
i really hope you guys enjoyed this and
these are the final standings of the
tournament uh maybe maybe after the
olympiad if you guys are interested i
was uh considering even showing all of
the games that you can play in this
tournament as uh it was a pretty pretty
brilliant showing uh
by alejand you can see that he won first
place ahead of all of these names uh
like i said uh
from the top names uh only capoblanca
and laskar were missing uh alejan wins
first place with 16 out of 20 with 12
wins zero losses and eight draws
followed by uh incre some incredible
legendary names like akiba rubinstein
friedrichsham chef in bogolu savali
tatakova frank marshall ilya rabinovic
and grunfeld aaron nimsowicz
all the way all the way in the back i
mean simply
a any incredible result for a
but even more incredible you know not
that he didn't lose a single game a lot
of players uh were able to win
tournaments without losing a single game
but with playing spectacular chess like
kalyakin did uh very very few people
throughout chess history who were able
to do just that
uh so yeah once again really hope you
guys enjoyed this and uh you know do
mention if you would like to see more uh
of aliens games from this tournament i'm
considering covering it in its entirety
so you know
maybe something to consider uh i would
like to thank uh omicron uh pico chess
kali ishmael rivera joshua figueroa
lintag and richard nickerson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world like i said uh the olympiad is
coming up uh
very soon uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day